correspondante sur place où en est-on de
l'afflux de réfugiés en pologne
j'ai juste devant la gare où il ya des
gens de crem qu'ils arrivent directement
de lévis ou une soeur du train pour
trouver en transport pour aller plus
loin
maintenant le troisième semaine de
l'invasion russe en ukraine on voit que
la situation est beaucoup plus calme
parce que le transport à beaucoup mieux
organisés donc les gens qu'ils arrivent
directement c'est ce qu'on appelle un
point d'accueil ici sans transporter
tout de suite soit vers la pologne dans
le ville plus grande où il ya beaucoup
plus de place que ici a affirmé ce n'est
pas d'une grande grande ville
ou sinon aussi à l'étrangère et s'est
réfugié en général ils sont ils de
passage ou ont-ils l'idée qu'ils sont
partis pour longtemps
je suis là a jamais changé pendant le
week-end j'ai aussi fait une visite à
lublin qui est pas loin de la frontière
je parlais avec des réfugiés qui venait
de craine ils me disaient c'était
c'était la moitié moitié il ya des gens
qui partent tout de suite en fait pour
retrouver leurs familles des amis dont
en pleurs ou ailleurs dans le pays et
européennes mais il ya aussi des gens
qui veulent rester près de la frontière
qui croivent que cette situation va se
calmer très bientôt et dans une semaine
peut-être deux semaines ils pourront
rentrer chez eux retrouvez leurs
partenaires les remercier leurs frères
qui sont restés en ukraine à cause de la
guerre merci beaucoup magdalena chonique
pour vos précisions merci à vous a dit